from water on Ukraine to what resembles
a war-torn Frankfurt this morning is the
ECB plans to inaugurate its new building
today over 10,000 protesters are trying
to spoil the party writers have set
several cars on fire protesting
austerity and capitalism I want to get
out to Frankfurt where Bloomberg's Jeff
black is at the protest Jeff these
protests they were well flagged the
police were organized what else has
happened this morning that might have
been a surprise to them I don't think
anything was a surprise to the police
they seem to have been extremely well
prepared I'm standing now in front of
the new ECB building and it is
barricaded off to the by the 500-meter
radius so everything here is common with
a minute at about seven-thirty local
time this morning there were clashes
between young black men throwing bottles
and cobble stones at police police moved
back and deployed water cannon and I
cleared that part of the protest art so
it's so far it's gone according to plan
this is how this kind of thing runs and
the police have be managed thing to deal
with it Jeff just gets the the business
end of things and the stuff that you
focus on day-to-day and that's the
economics of the whole situation for the
ECB and for Mario Draghi speaks today
are we expecting anything from that
speech no I think it's a ceremonial
event this has been long in the planning
their the new building has been very
long in the planning when this was all
conceived there was really no idea that
Europe would see the kind of people that
have seen and that this day would be
accompanied by such a level of protest
if they are they're trying to celebrate
a plan European moment and there are
people who are criticizing the way that
they do that and they're making
themselves heard today